steve karnacki breaking it down last
night
and uh the rams all of a sudden have to
worry
about missing the playoffs all together
one of the teams that was in that weird
weekly rotation of best team in the nfc
it goes from the saints to the
buccaneers to the packers to the rams to
the seahawks
and at one point it was the rams great
defense great running game
good enough to disguise the flaws or at
least
hide minimize look the other way pay no
attention to the man behind the curtain
flaws of jared goff
it looked like they had it going now
after losing to the jets
i thought they'd follow it up by
figuring out what they need to do and
beating the seahawks a team they
typically do well against chris
didn't happen and the rams in serious
trouble i still think they're going to
make it because i don't think the bears
are going to beat the packers since the
packers are still playing for the top
seed
yeah but they stay at least have to
spend the week worrying about not making
it which is something we didn't expect
they would be doing at this stage of the
season yeah no definitely
i mean that's not a given of course with
green bay going to chicago
chicago's kind of got their mojo going
either way but you know the rams are the
opposite of that i mean
they do have no mojo going right now
they lost three out of the last five
and you know they all all games have
similar qualities that just leave a bad
taste in your mouth
you know unimpressive offense bad
mistakes by jared goff
an inconsistent play from him at the
quarterback position i know he showed
great toughness yesterday hurting his
thumb i give him a lot of credit for
that i know he's tough
i know he's a good guy a good human um
but you know some of the stuff we see
quarterback yeah well there's there's
issues there you know it was
hey it was a tough it was going to be a
tough
defensive struggle football game
yesterday right
that's the way it was going to be it was
6-3 and the rams were winning and they
were winning that battle of we're gonna
play
field goals and defensive football no
problem it's 6-3 they're driving the
football they're in field goal range
and he decides to throw the ball across
his body
to a guy who's covered and behind
him and try to make some circus type
throw that
you know is just i wouldn't advise
patrick mahomes who makes those throws
routinely
to do and that really changed the
football game
you know they had a chance to really
kind of grab the the bull by the horns
there
and instead they gave the seahawks a
little life who were reeling a little at
that point
russell wilson goes down and kicks a
field goal makes it 6-6
and really the game was never the same
from that point on the the seahawks kind
of controlled
the the the flow of the football game
from there on out and we'll see with the
rams there's definitely concern with
that offense and how they look here
down the stretch we have all concluded
and i think the eagles well
have agreed by virtue of the fact that
they benched carson wentz that
they should not have given him a
gigantic contract extension after only
three seasons and now
it's time to have that conversation
about jared goff did the rams get it
wrong when they did the same thing and
the point i made last night
on twitter and i'm going to write about
this today pft chris 2015
jameis winston first pick marcus mariota
second pick
their teams never seriously considered
extending them
they played five years each they got
their fifth year option that big balloon
payment that you get
in year five and then they walked away
and
the next year goffin wentz after only
three seasons each get gigantic
contracts
and the eagles clearly regret it and the
rams if you applied sean mcvay
to a lie detector machine or injected
sodium pentathol into his veins would
say
i regret it how can they not regret it
chris
i i i know i i don't know you know it's
they they they traded up in the draft to
get their quarterbacks
jared goff went to a super bowl carson
wentz
played at an mvp caliber you know
level for just about a full season and
of course the team went on to win a
super bowl
and they fell in that trap of you know
yeah okay we gotta sign it he's the face
of our franchise these are our guys
and of course with what they did the
trade up in the draft yeah they put
themselves in a corner that way
you know the difference being though the
rams barely have had backup quarterbacks
there to threaten jared goff
where the eagles have had somebody
competent behind him
and that's going to be the big thing
this week can jared goff play
i mean that offense isn't that great
with jared goff in it
i don't know about what it's going to
look like with their backup quarterback
i mean
that's going to be interesting to see
and maybe the biggest game of the year
for this football team
and can they beat kyla murray in them
you know with a less than jared goff
or no jared goff we'll see
and here's where it stands jared goff
had that dislocated thumb yesterday he
popped it back in he kept going
you can see he was in pain he was in
discomfort he said after the game he's
uncertain that he'll be able
to play i've confirmed that there is
indeed a fracture in the thumb they're
going to evaluate it more today to
decide what he can
and can't do he's adamant about playing
reportedly of course he is every
every professional athlete is adamant
about playing the question is can he
physically do it
and this is the analysis we went through
not long ago it's it's
not very high level but it should be
easy to understand
what percentage are you willing to
tolerate from your starter
below 100 before you turn to a fully
healthy
backup in new orleans x percent drew
brees
one over 100 taysom hill in
la what percent jared goff is going to
win
over 100 percent john walford all due
respect
john walford anybody who even plays that
pays the the closest attention to the
game
who's john walford he played in the aaf
he's never thrown a pass in a regular
season nfl game
and here's the here's the where it gets
dicey for goth if walford actually plays
fairly well
that's only going to increase the
chatter that maybe goff's not the guy
that sean mcvay's the guy sean mcvay's
the reason if walford plays well you're
going to hear
and the media machine this this this
bizarre pro mcvey media machine
chris that's out there and they know who
they are they're already hyping walford
as a guy who's going to come in and play
well because he's hitched to mcvay
well i mean i'm sure it's easy to do
that
you know mcveigh's pretty damn good when
he's been with the rams quarterback play
has been pretty damn good and
you know jared goff we know is not that
special
he went to the super bowl with a
quarterback that
i don't know if anybody in their right
mind would say is in the top 20
quarterbacks in football
so yeah there's a chance and that's
where the rams mis-evaluated just on
your point in my opinion i mean
you know again it's it's it's not that
hard to run bootlegs and play actions
and screens you could there are a lot of
quarterbacks in football that could run
that rams offense a lot of them
and then they could have used maybe that
extra 15 20 million dollars
for another offensive lineman or another
defensive lineman next to aaron donald
and
they could be more dominant i don't know
somebody's going to do this here soon
like we've talked about at the
quarterback position where they just go
wait it's not really that special he's
throwing four-yard passes
and he's throwing it we could have got
johnny from high school to do that
so let's not give him a piece of the
franchise to be their quarterback
somebody will do it but either way the
rams are reeling
as good as their defense is playing
right now uh
the fact that they just can't put up
points on the offensive side of the ball
that is concerning and that goes on more
than jared goff that's mcveigh too
you know it's strugglesville right there
right now it's not a lot of yards per
play
and uh they haven't dominated the line
of scrimmage and they just seem
off-kilter all together here the last
few weeks
do we give any credence to the argument
chris that we made last year when the
colts signed phillip rivers that they
needed to give him that 25 million
contracts kind of like the lawyer has to
drive a cadillac you have to have a
certain cachet
you have to have that swag in the locker
room that so you can lead sure
the idea that you have to show
conviction and confidence in your
quarterback and you give him that
contract
it's good for his ego it's good for his
confidence it's good
for his ability to lead in the locker
room
uh are you buying that as a reason for
paying guys like goffin wentz now with
wence wence that it just
it just it just went away yeah he he had
it and it's gone right with goth you
could argue it was never really
well i i just think teams have gone
overboard on it
like i i just i think like if the
quarterback was making 20 million
dollars a year
everybody in the locker room would still
go that's the man he's making a lot more
than all of us
like but we've made it like we're like
hey he's part of the owner of the team
him and the owner talk they don't he
doesn't really talk they put
quarterbacks in a different stratosphere
with what they pay hey you're worth our
whole offensive line you're worth all of
them and more
like what that's where it's gone that's
where it has to change in my opinion
and you know i'll bring this up we talk
about that like to your point because
mike you're
it's a real point you're right that i
think there's a lot of thinking in the
nfl that way
but i would also say like i i think the
colts and that team would look at philip
rivers the same way as they do right now
if he was making 18 million dollars
and i think the patriots players really
respect cam newton and he's making
peanuts
so it just shows you if you could act
the right way and be a true leader
and be accountable and all that guys
will still think you're the man whether
you're making 7
10 15 20. it doesn't matter
cam newton's on pace to make 3.7 billion
for his one season with the patriots
jared goff's making 33 and a half
million per year
and and you know you know what if if you
told me
i had 33 and a half million to spend and
i could only spend it on one guy
goff or mcvay i'm spending it on mcvay
knock off and that that's another point
too coach coach
great coaches don't get paid nearly
what they're worth because mcvay's more
important to that team
than goff is mcveigh's the one who
should be making 33.5 million if anyone
is between the two of them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports